well welcome back to the New York New
Jersey area because you just got back
from Italy visiting with your husband
Joe there so how was the reunion with
Joe in Italy it was amazing yeah I was
great a lot of happy tears it was just
like I was so overwhelmed seeing how
happy my daughters were a happy Joe was
I was like I was like over the moon just
it was just it was just great to see
them reunite yeah you know after all
this time I mean because you hadn't seen
him basically in nearly four years
because he's been serving jail time for
I'm gonna seen him like I want to go see
him
you know at the imprison right and at
the one place we were able to see each
other face to face but then when he went
to ice he was behind a glass so and that
was terrible but so you were you were
able to see one another freely with
everything any sort of like confinement
out he's totally free that's it like you
know him now he that he's in Italy he
you know he's not on probation not that
he's free as can be so this is the first
time that you all we saw the two of you
exchanged words with in the public
setting of sorts because you had an
interview with Andy Cohen of course and
the interview was kind of contentious at
times if Teresa decides to file for
divorce is there is there do you
understand why she would do that listen
as long as she's happy you know that's
all that really matters I mean I'm not
gonna you know tell her what to do I
can't you know I mean it's if she
doesn't feel like she wants to be with
me anymore then you know that's the
thing to do
how we gonna live apart I don't think
like that he would be faithful I don't I
know I think you'd have someone there
and have me here and I just don't want
to live that life I just don't you had a
feeling of like the two of you just the
sense of like defeat between the two of
you so how are things
now you said in that interview with Andy
that you had to see each other to know
where your relationship was standing and
how you would move forward so where are
things now well this trip to Italy was
all about the kids it was all about the
kids you know being together with their
dad and and just Joe and I being in a
good place which we were and I mean I
really can't like I can't really give
you a straight-up answer because it was
like that we work together two and a
half days so I mean we're just taking
day by day and see you know what I see
what happens
did you have time to spend just
one-on-one together not really
no now I mean we did have a talk which
you'll see play out you know in season
10 okay so you'll see you had a
conversation for the Real Housewives
cameras yes between the two of you do
you feel like you've resolved things
between the two of you within your
marriage or do you feel like there's
still a lot that needs to happen no
we're both in a good place you know we
both want each other to be happy which
that's the most important thing and our
both common denominator is our four
daughters like we just want and of
course we're gonna do what it takes to
you know for the happiness of our
daughters so that's that's that's our
goal like as long as they're happy we're
happy and of course they want us to be
happy like like there's not gonna be any
bickering or anything like that like so
past that you know and I think where he
was he was like you know and he was in a
bad place
so he took a lot of frustrations out on
the kids and myself because he was in a
you know he was in a hellhole he
basically you know that's where he was
how long was he and ice seven months Wow
I mean there was people cutting
themselves in there like he didn't even
tell us all of this until he came out
like they were cutting the wrist cutting
their throats you know it was like
really bad bad conditions he said it was
like where he was an ice was worse than
like this whole jail time Wow yeah so
it's like really bad like it's so it's
so sad like not only for our family for
other people that that are going through
the same thing
it's like even people that aren't I said
one of the
leave ice they can't even leave ice
unbelievable yeah it's really sad this
whole thing that's going on with that
you know you said in the interview with
Andy that you you were nervous about
seeing Joe well I was I was just feeling
just kind of goat that that nervous
feeling go away did you still have those
nerve I was really really nervous and
until I got there and then it was so
weird like after Ike when I got to Italy
and like um you know cuz we had a drive
from Naples to Salerno I mean for me to
drive from Naples to sala consilina
you know where that's where we saw a job
right and I don't know it's just then
once we got there it was like I felt a
sense of relief like that finally you
know my girl my daughters get till you
reunite with their dad and I knew it was
just gonna be amazing and they got to
see you know what an amazing family he
has there and he does he does have like
a great support system it's so important
to have that support system I mean it
God I mean you know Joe is lucky to have
that like I feel bad for other people
that get deported to these countries
that they had no no one there you know
it's really sad so and I remember seeing
a photo on your Instagram I'm just like
ginormous family group you know yeah I'm
hosing her fam art for a photo and it
was just nice to see like that was is
the support system there you know yeah
he does I mean that's what he says he's
like you know it's great I have a great
support system hearings big but my heart
is with my daughter's yeah like he wants
to be here in America with his daughters
that's what he said he's like it's not
the same he said you know even though
I'm so grateful for my family but he's
like it's you know it's I don't have my
daughters here right yeah understandable
so when you saw him you felt a sense of
relief but did you feel a sense of
attraction I don't I mean you know him
he looks great
he's definitely very cleaned up he's
very leaned up yes he's very leaned up I
mean yeah he looks great but used to
call him like mister
see he's a lien I think she's not juicy
but did you feel like oh my gosh that's
my Joe that's my husband um listen I'm
always gonna love him and it's you know
it's been a long time so it's like we I
was we didn't have any alone time or
anything so it was like basically it was
just all about our daughters yeah it
really was
so tell me about that the daughters your
daughter's seeing him for the first time
what was their immediate reaction when
they saw their oh my god they were so
overjoyed yeah you'll see a play on
camera they were just so happy it was
just like you know I was so happy for
that I was like finally you know they
get to be with their dad and they adore
him
they really do like they absolutely
adore him and you know vice versa and he
adores them I think they've been
facetiming with each other right you
know cuz he's been he was out like a
month and we waited till teachers
convention to the girls head off from
school so that's why we waited which was
good because you know his media like his
mom his brother his sister they all went
before I think you get him acclimated to
his new home yes which was great and
then and then he's living like he has
his own mom's home there that you know
is his grandmother's home that left it
to the kids so he has a hat home there
but matter-of-fact you guys don't see
like he had just hailey
he already has he got his own apartment
you know he already got a car so he's
making his way he's bigger here I doubt
he's gonna pull it out I feel like it's
interesting to see in the season
premiere for Real Housewives New Jersey
I feel like we see you and your
daughters interacting conversing
communicating and really speaking openly
about you and Joe's experience in prison
you never really were one to want to
even use the word prison in the past
when speaking with them so how and why
did that kind of shift in the
conversation evolve between you and the
girls well I was pretty much talking to
my older daughters but not really the
baby they're old enough now to know that
you know everything that's been you know
going eyes this has been going on for
four years like a long time right I was
there you know eleven and a half months
but Joe's been there now for a while
right so so any of Geo's 18 Gabrielle is
15 and Milani is 14 so I mean I think
they're old enough now to like you know
hear the truth do you think they're oh
and even now the baby knows like you
know that you know Joe was in prison him
and she's ten now it still it so yeah
yeah I know it is I mean but you know
she does hear things and she's really
smart and she's such an amazing amazing
little girl she really is do you think
they fully understand outside of Gia
they fully understand that their dad may
never return to the US I'm sure they're
like a little confused by it they don't
know it but they know that you know
listen we're still fighting it so you
know we're not gonna give up until the
end gia has just evolved into really a
remarkable young lady she is outspoken
yet she can't choose her words wisely
though she's wise with her words she's
smart she just seems to have it together
she's pursuing college so how proud are
you of Gia no so proud yeah I'm proud of
them all they really are amazing like
Gabrielle isn't an honor student she's
at all on her classes she's in varsity
she's a freshman and she's on the
varsity team and saw on soccer she made
that Milania is you know Milani had a
hard time last year but this year she's
doing amazing she turned it all around
and that's what I kept on I'm like
listen what happened to your dad you
know you can't keep harping over it you
know you this is your life you you know
you you got to live your life you can't
you know I understand you're upset about
daddy but this is you have one life to
live and live it the best way you can
like because you know she was really
upset over it and and that's the thing
in this whole thing like you know us
adults like Jo and I will be fine
because we're adults and of course we'll
make it through because we have no
choice but this whole thing who it is
effect
the girls it affects the kids and that's
sad because any of I'm just saying in
this world that we live in it's like you
want the world to be a better place and
the children are the new generation it's
like why you want to hurt them like
after you've done your time and you've
done what you had to do you know it's
like I don't understand why you have to
keep punishing people I mean it's sad
yeah especially for a white-collar crime
that's paper true but do you feel like
woulda shoulda coulda I wish that I
could go back and do things differently
so why not affect my daughters in this
guy meanie I mean that's something that
you would have - Joe you know cuz that
you know I had you know I really had
nothing to do with it and and I did my
time like I just I took responsibility
for what happened but I'm just saying
like we both did our time and it's sad I
mean no not only just for us for other
families that are going through this
also do you feel like maybe you're being
used as an example of course yeah hello
where am i right now I have all these
cameras now II know but I mean just from
your perspective yes you have all these
cameras around other words I mean I
think if I was a regular person that if
I wasn't I'd say maybe Joe would have
still went to prison you never know yeah
tell you I don't know I'm still like up
in the air with that yes and no but I
think I would have definitely never gone
like you know if I wasn't in the public
eye because I you know is there anything
that you wish that you wouldn't have
shared on the show no no no listen you
can't scribe over spilled milk you just
gotta move forward okay fair enough and
that's the whole purpose of the show -
is did an exact share at all
good bad another highs right exactly um
it seems to me that you and Joe you want
to make sure that the happiness that
you're setting your daughters up for
success and their happiness but that the
two of you are seemingly done that
you're going your separate ways I mean
why do you say that I
just because of I mean like the deflate
the defeated nough stand felt along the
way with the Andy Cohen interview with
your seemingly putting your daughter's
first which is fantastic but do you feel
like you are gonna sever ties in part
ways completely I mean we haven't
decided yet to eat our plane ride in
Italy you know I live in America I don't
know if that's gonna work if if it ends
up happening that way and so I mean
right now I couldn't decide my life in
two and a half days that go you know we
didn't decide like what we're gonna do
like right now it's I mean it was really
short that I was there so we're just
taking them day by day and okay we're
gonna see what happens so the verdicts
still out with what how things will yes
Berger how it's gonna prayer but I mean
so many people are rooting for you guys
and that everyone's just happy at the
end of all of that thank you I do have
to address the cheating rumors though
because that was something that the two
of you were kind of going to it for tat
for in the interview with Andy Cohen's
do I feel like he was faithful ya know
you don't know I don't like that she
took a photo with another man but I mean
I've asked her about the guy I mean she
says that he's I don't know this friend
I mean I don't know what kind of fun
maybe you know I don't know if there has
been long-running speculation even
before the criminal case and the charges
came forward that Joe was possibly
cheating on you so do you feel like that
was something that was happening in the
past I mean I never caught him I mean he
was photographed of people he said you
know nothing happened so you know I
believed him obviously because we still
stayed together but I guess that's so
that's like in the past now and I'm
gonna psyche whatever mm-hmm Laurie
Lachlan so we've seen her name pop up
time and time again right now in the
news because of the college scandal so
what is some advice that you might have
for Laurie and her family especially if
she indeed has to face time in prison
for her charges listen I you know
sure shall be you know I'm sure she'll
make it through women are all women I
feel like where women are strong we have
babies we do it all I'm sure whatever
outcome it is I'm sure she'll be fine
with it but you know it's in particular
she's a mom of two daughters so what
would you advise maybe how should she
prepare them if she does facetiming her
and her daughter's are older I guess I
mean you know she did it for her
daughters and I mean I'm sure her
daughters are grateful for what she did
I mean you know she was just looking out
for her daughters and trying to get them
into a good school but I mean and I
guess that's it I mean I guess just be
open with them and and whatever the
outcome is it is we have to deal with it
and move forward all right so this
season the trailer for Real Housewives
New Jersey OMG versus cocktailing it up
all night with some young guy okay I was
kidding Theresa she's out of control
it's embarrassing I'm gonna bury your
head spins just watching the trailer you
know but there are some some of the
women this season are really attacking
you and saying that you are drinking too
much you're out there socializing way
too much that you're a mess you're a
ticking time bomb do you think that you
were
now were you just like socializing and
trying to like get your life I was just
doing me
yeah me and Teresa Giudice Oh which at
this phase in your life at this point in
your life who is Teresa Giudice I'm
standing strong I am Who I am and you
know I'm confident I like if you know
I'm just it's like why I can't have a
drink like what's wrong with that it's
like you know I can't socialize like
what's wrong it bad do you think it was
that you were out socializing or rather
maybe who it was so you were socializing
nobody's business who I socialize with
there you know I mean like I was you
know I have a good time just like they
have a good time so if they have
something say they could save to my face
and I will respond if you keep poking
out of bear
eventually the Bears gonna eat your lock
and it seems like a lot of them are from
what I've gathered I haven't seen the
entire season but they're speculating a
lot about your personal life your
romantic life your love life that
doesn't like that's what women do so is
a lot of this season you know focusing
on their speculating of your love life
um no I mean maybe the beginning yeah
but then it changes into other you know
is there any reason for them to
speculate no no okay um Danielle Staub
she returns so what is that looking
light because it seems that that
friendship is kind of says old I hang it
why do you say that just from some you
know the lack of her presence and things
like that so what is your friendship
like nowadays oh I guess you're gonna
have to tune in to see where our
friendship stands right now okay all
right
finally what how do you hope your life
looks in 5-10 years hmm
I'll never answer that question ever
Cristobal I wish I did there were things
like there are short-term girls goals
that I have in life
things that I would like to work toward
so what are some things that you would
like to world war night words when I
started the show like I I got asked that
question all the time and I answered it
I never saw myself in prison ever so
like now I'll never answer that question
ever again like I'll have like you know
I guess goals in my head but I never
want to you know like it I'll put them
out in the universe for myself but I
don't want to just voice and math to
just the world just because that's how I
feel now just because of what happened
to me is one of your hopes maybe to be
happily married and reunited with Joe
one of my hopes is to be happy and in
love and to live happily ever after yes
with or without you exactly for both of
us and I'm always gonna love Joe he's
always gonna love me we're always gonna
be a family our goal is to focus always
on our four daughters
you